Естонія та Фінляндія межують із Росією і
входять до Європейського Союзу які
заборонив авіаперевезення з Росії після
її вторгнення в Україну однак як довго
росіяни ще зможуть добиратися до Естонії
та Фінляндії суходолом невідомо
російській компанії пропонують
автомобільні поїздки з Петербурга до
столиці Фінляндії Гельсінки між містами
приблизно 300 км
на мій погляд так видача віз росіянам
має бути обмежена неправильно що тоді
коли Росія веде агресивну війну в Європі
російські туристи можуть вільно
подорожувати але Це складне питання
справа не лише в тому які візи видає
Фінляндія Оскільки ми входимо до
Шенгенської зони це також питання
шенгенських віз ми маємо обговорити це
разом з іншими європейськими країнами на
рівні ЄС та разом знайти рішення
серед 26 країн шенгенської зони 22
держави Євросоюзу а також Ісландія
Норвегія Швейцарія та Ліхтенштейн
заборонити видавати візи можна лише за
згодою всіх країн-учасниць Шенгенської
угоди поки що рішення на Європейському
рівні немає заявили у МЗС Німеччини
У рамках рішення Ради з міжнародних
відносин від 25 лютого прийнято рішення
на рівні ЄС про часткове скасування
угоди про полегшення режиму це особливо
стосується скасування безвізового в'їзду
для власників дипломатичних паспортів і
скасування полегшень для членів
парламенту та уряду що стосується видачі
вісто скасування видачі шенгенських віз
може бути введена лише на підставі
консенсусу між усіма країнами
Шенгенської угоди А зараз такого рішення
немає
9 серпня зупинити видачу туристичних віз
росіянам на поїздки до ЄС закликала
примірка Естонії Кая Калаш відвідування
Європи привілей а не право людини
авіасполучення з Росією закрито це
означає що поки країна Шенгенської зони
видають візи тягар несуть сусіди Росії
Фінляндія Естонія Латвія наземні точки
в'їзду час припиняти туризм з Росії вже
зараз
на початку тижня президент України
Володимир Зеленський закликав країни
заходу заборонити в'їзд на свою
територію всім громадянам Росії Він
вважає що заборона має торкнутися
зокрема тих хто залишив Росію через
незгоду з війною в Україні
найважливіші санкції закрити кордони бо
росіяни захоплюють чужу територію хай
вони живуть у своєму власному світі поки
не змінять свою філософію
у Кремлі вже зазначили що будь-які
спроби ізолювати росіян Чи Росію це
цитатам процес який не має перспектив І
що ірраціональність мислення тих хто це
пропонує зашкалює європейські ж політики
прості громадяни нагадують Росії чому це
зроблено
гинуть громадяни України мирні жителі
жінки і діти в Україні а з іншого боку
громадяни Росії відпочивають у ЄС Я
вважаю що це нестерпна ситуація
це неправильно що росіяни можуть вільно
їздити до Фінляндії це позбавляє підстав
для санкцій Я думаю що повинні бути
певні обмеження
проти цього рішення виступають деякі
бізнесмени які ведуть бізнес з Росією і
відповідно самі туристи з РФ
Я вважаю що це найабсурдніша ідея Яка у
них є
що вони виграють від ізоляції нормальних
російських громадян які не мають жодного
відношення до політичних рішень лідерів
Росії
вони створюють проблеми для нормальних
російських громадян і вони створюють
величезну проблему для місцевих жителів
і бізнесу тут
мені буде дуже сумно Я розчарований тому
що я дуже люблю Фінляндію і мені
подобається Тут відпочивати це чудова
країна природа й озера я буду
розчарований
туристичні візи громадянам Росії наразі
не видають країни Балтії дані а Бельгія
Нідерланди Мальта Чехія та Словаччина
Латвія ще навесні вирішила не видавати
росіянам туристичні візи але зберігалися
можливість отримання довгострокових
національних Віса для роботи чи з
гуманітарних міркувань на початку серпня
Латвія припинила видавати росіянам
будь-які візи єдиний виняток похорон
близьких родичів
[музика]
».»
зробити декілька випадків коли країна
видавала статус біженця тим хто
побоюється або кого вже переслідують
відкрили кримінальні справи в Росії
Росії
яку будь-якому демократичному
суспільстві у демократичній країні тут є
різні погляди на цю ситуацію
міністри закордонних справ країн ЄС
обговорять питання щодо віз для росіян
неформальні зустрічі 31 серпня